China is invading other countries with  secret police to the outside they're  saying they're just trying to catch  Chinese phone scammers who have fled  China but instead of working with local  law enforcement to catch these criminals  China is illegally sending in their own  secret police force to round them up  without ever charging them with a crime  and these secret police are willing to  do anything to get these Chinese back  home they'll threaten their jobs freeze  their bank accounts block their kids  from attending school cancel health  benefits and even threaten family  members this sends a message to Chinese  people everywhere no matter how far you  go you can never escape the Chokehold of  the Chinese governments make sure to  subscribe for more